[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who always
strikes first when it comes to posting
breakdowns this video we're going to be
doing a deep dive with kobrakai season 4
and going over not only its story but
also the ending it'll leave some big
things up in the air for the future and
though we don't know what's happening
next time we can use what's set up in
the series to predict what could be
coming down the line now if you enjoy
the video then please show no mercy on
that like button and also don't forget
to subscribe for puns that will crease
you up every time or cringe you out now
without the way thanks for clicking this
now let's get into kobra kai season 4.
okay so season 4 opens with somewhat of
a last jedi moment as we watch the other
side of the big phone call that ended
the last entry we find terry silva
living it up in his mansion playing
piano but he immediately terminates the
call with crease and goes back to being
a millionaire however crease doesn't
stop and he slowly pulls his old war
buddy back into the fray after
convincing him that kobakai is life in
case you haven't seen karate kid 3 terry
ended up terry rising teenagers
throughout the summer of 89 and before
his team were beaten he announced that
he'd be opening multiple karbakai dojos
terry told his students to use illegal
moves but daniel still came out on top
because of this kobra kai were
embarrassed and his plans were shut down
but they somewhat come to fruition in
the season which sets up a lot of things
for the future now after being convinced
by crease that he needs to come back
into it silva is very much like oh [ __ ]
here we go again initially he's very
reluctant to return but slowly he cracks
over time and ends up becoming the
biggest villain that we've had so far
the season has several themes going on
in it that all sort of play into the
ending and this includes fathers and
sons as well as fractured alliances
though we ended season 3 with daniel and
johnny teaming up they quickly see that
they're not a good fit and the pair are
very sensative about their decisions
being overridden by the other this is
very much merit increase in silver who
end up going their separate ways too
after the ladder becomes power hungry
and cuts chris off kobrakai is very much
about getting rid of one's weaknesses
and due to the life debt that silva owes
to crease he realizes that he's his thus
he decides to iron out crease and silva
ends up giving him the chop in the final
few scenes mr stelia dojo frames him for
attempted murder along with the help of
stingray which we'll talk about in just
a bit now in the background of this we
meet a new character called kenny who
very much goes through the same cycles
that we've seen the other characters do
just as i was about to compliment
anthony larusso for losing all that
weight he turns out to be a dick that
bullies kenny until he has no other
option but to become an absolute
psychopath they have an unintentionally
hilarious spot in episode 7 where he
goes into predator mode and takes out
his bullies one by one in a library and
i think going forward it's obviously
going to be him versus anthony at the
next door valley what do you call
anthony larusso daniel sun hey
having that what a terrific audience
thank you thank you very much now
everything builds up towards the old
valley which unlike previous years now
will have a male and female champion
things are pretty neck and neck but
there's a big twist when miguel injures
his back attempting to do a 900 degree
spin kick given half an hour to recover
miguel ends up deciding to step away
from the tournament after realizing that
all johnny cares about is beating crease
and also lapusso he tells miguel that
it's time to become a man in stepper but
in doing this he'll actually just be
living for johnny who clearly doesn't
have his best interests at heart even
though the kid's recovering from a
broken back and has badly hurt himself
johnny would gladly put him in harm's
way so he can win though he doesn't
realize it he's very similar to greece
who too would put johnny in danger for a
chance at victory though miguel saw
somewhat of a father and johnny he
realizes at this point that he was only
filling the hole that robbie left in his
life now just before going to miguel
chris and johnny have a heart to heart
in which crease says that he very much
saw johnny as the son that he never had
throughout the season we learned more
about johnny's childhood and how his
father ran away johnny kept his old beer
cans and things that he left behind but
his mother threw these out which
explains why he ended up gravitating so
much towards crease in order to fill
this hole in his life as we touched upon
earlier the karate kid in kobakai are
very much centered around father and son
relationships you of course had mr
miyagi and daniel chris and johnny
johnny and robbie johnny miguel danny
and anthony and so on and so forth
however all of the fatherly figures are
pushing their sons to be a certain way
which ultimately leads into a cycle of
repeated violence miguel is really the
first one to break completely free of
this and the season ends with him
heading to mexico city to try and find
his dad throughout the seasons we've had
lip service paid to him being a bad guy
that probably spoiled no way home for
everyone he leaves behind a note for his
mother saying that he was so focused on
the tournament as he thought that it
would take his mind off everything
however it hasn't and thus he needs to
dive into the past to find out who he
really is there's just one big problem
though miguel's father doesn't know he
exists as his mother clearly left before
giving birth to him now going forward i
don't think his father will be a
character from the previous films but he
will likely be a pretty bad guy if
carmen didn't even want him to know that
they were having a kid together seeing
how bad he is might put miguel on the
path to return to johnny as he realizes
that though he pushed him it's because
he wanted him to do well now on a meta
level charlo married yuenya is gonna be
playing blue beetle in the dc eu it's
possible that he might not even be in
the next season due to scheduling
conflicts and we have seen that they've
removed actors for entire entries such
as share i'm not 100 when that starts
filming but potentially miguel might
play a lesser role come the next season
before he returns for the one after this
would give him time to grow but it's
going to be interesting to see how they
handle things now as for the old valley
we culminate with robbie and eli going
head to head in one of the tensest
fights so far elia mages on top and
because of this miyagido falls into the
overall lead however the fight between
tory and sam is the one that will
determine which side clenches the
victory guided by silva torri ends up
using illegal moves much like his
protege mike barnes in karate kid 3.
tory almost sides with silver and
hitting below the belt but after getting
flashbacks to how aggressive he was to
johnny crease tells tory to do what she
wants as this is her fight unlike the
rest of the adults he's clearly realized
that the kid should be going in their
own direction this is instead of being
forced down a dark path by one of them
and he's the first adult to really break
this cycle tori ends up taking it but
this is a hollow victory as she catches
silva's conversation with the ref after
getting the trophy terry also announces
that they're opening a franchises of
cobra kai throughout the valley and both
daniel and sam end up leaving defeated
they tried to do the right thing and
fight fairly but was still beaten by the
cheating cobra now this puts tory in
somewhat somewhat of a moral quandary as
cobra kai will probably just continue to
pay off the referees in all the upcoming
tournaments this will not only rob the
other teams of a victory but also those
at cobra kai as they'll not really be
winning simply just cheating in order to
get a victory actually thing come the
next season tori will expose this and
potentially end up even joining one of
the other dojos she tried throughout the
series to bury the hatchet with sam and
potentially next time she might actually
do it i think terry has set himself up
to get exposed quite a lot as there's
also stingray who could bring him down
episode 10 actually opens with him in a
hospital bed after getting brutally
beaten up by terry silva now at the end
of the episode it's revealed that he
actually pinned the attack on crease
because like he said he'll do anything
for kobakai this includes framing the
cobra guy who wasn't very nice to him
and told him that he wasn't cut out to
join the dojo as terry and chris sits
celebrating that victory over two
glasses of champagne his terrifying plan
is finally revealed every silver lining
has a cloud and realizing that chris had
a moment of sympathy with dory he sees
how weak he is he reveals that he knows
creases weaknesses johnny lawrence and
all the talk about bringing back the
good old days is just bs as we talked
about earlier chris always classed
johnny as his son and having him
constantly in the back of his mind means
that he'll never fully achieve greatness
now though he sided with terry stink
right sorry stingray is probably gonna
realize that he's not a good guy i can
see him bringing what really happened
into the light and this will likely get
chris off however with silva still in
control of the dojo it's going to be
difficult for him to return to kobakai
therefore i can't see crease actually
joining up with johnny and finally the
pair will be a team with creases new
enlightenment now this idea of old
enemies teaming up will also be
reflected in chosin who makes an
alliance with daniel at the end of the
season chosen was someone that we were
reintroduced to during cobra kai season
3 and though in the karate kid 2 he used
to hold knives up to women's throats all
was forgiven now in episode 5 of the
previous entry they put their
differences aside and though i wasn't
expecting to see chosen back i'm really
glad he's returned chosen is far more of
a vicious fighter than daniel and he's
exactly what miyagido needs in order to
stand a chance against the new cobra kai
franchise model daniel vows to go on the
offense instead of playing defense and
with chosen at his side they might
actually stand a chance have you cast
your mind back to chosen's return in
season 3 then you might remember that he
knew of a secret technique that miyagi
had never told daniel this involved
paralyzing someone by hitting special
pressure points in their body and shows
and instilled this wisdom in daniel if
you cast your mind back to episode 5 of
season 3 then you might remember that
chosen gave daniel the scroll for his
collection chozin was very much hinted
towards being taught a lot of things
that mr miyagi wouldn't teach daniel i
think that going forward he will be very
much the chosen one come on now that
that pun was staring us all in the face
yeah i couldn't resist it i'm not that
strong now it's gonna be interesting to
see what happens next time but those are
my predictions for how things are gonna
go if you have any other theories i'd
love to know so drop them below and send
it to the internet now as for my review
the show went down better than a random
appearance by carrie underwood singing
whatever the [ __ ] it was she was singing
for as formulaic and almost cheesier
points that cobra kai is i can't get
enough of it and i got goosebumps
watching the final scene play out these
guys know what they're doing when it
comes to crafting a fun and entertaining
series that doesn't take itself too
seriously and you could argue that this
is the best season so far not only does
this entry bring back characters like
aisha for some brief moments but it also
develops new ones such as kenny and
anthony la puso let's be honest at this
point the show is pretty much built
around a cycle of violence where one
character and his mates beat up another
and then that character gets revenge
which causes the other character to
retaliate you can pretty much predict
all the ways that the rivalries are
gonna go but come the end of the season
when we get the all valley you're so
caught up in it that you're desperate
for your favorite to win what kobrakai
does brilliantly though is that it also
makes their opponent your favorite too
and whilst technically you can't have
two favorites what i mean by that is
that it's difficult to actually pick a
side whilst you're watching it though
cobra kai are often depicted as the
quote-unquote bad guys i was constantly
cheering for tori and robbie to win just
as much as i was the other side and it
shows how well they've managed to craft
this story every character has something
you can relate to and even satan himself
aka kris gave me something in this
season where i felt bad for the guy
that's great writing even if the writing
isn't always great another show isn't
exactly prestige television i'd much
rather be watching this than another
season of westworld just don't tell
people who watched my westworld
breakdowns that i said that yeah now
when we look at kobrakai as a show it
too is the underdog competing amongst
all these massive properties on tv but
it's managed to put the work in give us
what we want and rise to the top the
season had so many good themes going on
with it as well such as the father and
son relationships that we saw standing
up to bullies and how one should try and
work with their enemies in order to
better the future plus there's the
fights and over the seasons these have
got stronger and stronger as the
choreography has got better and better i
know a point it's a bit ridiculous
seeing people doing roundhouse kicks at
pool parties and characters like
stingray are just parodies at this point
but you know what who cares the shout is
way more good than bad has its tongue in
its cheek all the time but it also has a
heart to it and an emotion that we see
beautifully portrayed in the deepest
storylines if you don't like karma kai
already then i don't think this will win
you around but it's such an easy binge
that i think those who adore it will
whizz right through it it's not exactly
citizen kane is it but i think it's one
of those shows that should get a 10 out
of 10 because it's just what you want to
see when you're a fan when i reviewed it
on twitter i gave it a 9 out of 10 but
what am i knocking a point off for no
one takes these reviews that seriously
anyway so [ __ ] it just give it a 10 make
more of these and we'll have a good time
in a world that's so cold and dark thank
you again cobra kai you once more end of
the year on a high and i can't wait to
see what happens next now and of course
love to hear your thoughts so make sure
you comment below and let me know we're
on a competition right now and giving
away three copies of an mcu boxer of
your choice on the 30th of january and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
book of boba fett which will be linked
on screen right now we went over the
first episode pointing out all the
easter eggs we could find and talked
about what could be happening in the
future so definitely go check it out
right after this without the way thanks
for clicking this i hope you have a good
new year and 2022 and hopefully i'll see
you on the channel a lot more thanks for
sitting through the video peace